from a viking Revenge tale to the true
story of a boxing Legend these films are
worth checking out even though they
didn't make much cash
although he's been one of Hollywood's
top screenwriters ever since he pinned
Lethal Weapon in 1987. Shane black
didn't make his directorial debut until
2005 with Kiss Kiss Bang Bang his
hilarious Noir flavored comedy with
bursts of action proved that black knew
what he was doing behind the camera
after directing Iron Man 3 black
returned with another Noir action comedy
hybrid in 2016. the nice guys
with a clever script a fun 70s La
setting creative action sequences and
excellent Chemistry Between the Stars
Russell Crowe and Ryan Gosling the nice
guys is easy to love what wasn't easy on
the other hand was making back its 50
million dollar budget at the box office
though much larger audiences eventually
came around to the film once it hit
streaming services the nice guys only
brought in 36 million dollars
domestically a massive drop-off from
Black's over 1.2 billion dollar earning
MCU Endeavor you know nobody got hurt
people got her I'm saying I think they
died quickly though so I don't think
that they got hurt black returned to
franchise filmmaking with his next
outing in the form of the Predator but
again failed to make back the film's
budget at the domestic box office once
again
Peter Strickland isn't a name that comes
up often when the best horror directors
of the 21st century are being discussed
but maybe that ought to change much like
Strickland's earlier film Barbarian
Sound Studio and later film Flex Gourmet
and fabric is a stylish good time rather
than slotting into the current trends of
modern Horror in fabric instead looks to
the past the film is styled like an
Italian gialo film from the 70s and uses
that aesthetic to present the story of A
Haunted dress as it exchanges
unfortunate owners a reverent tribute to
director Dario Argento and his film
Suspiria in particular fans of this Emmy
forgotten era of Italian horror will
find a lot to Love in This film
especially the film's soundtrack
composed by the band Cavern of
antimatter
Strickland's three horror films so far
have all greatly impressed critics but
have failed to connect successfully with
General audiences in the same way in
fabric became Strickland's most
critically acclaimed horror outing to
date when it was released in 2018 but it
lacked the reach necessary to earn back
its budget at the box office
despite having the largest budget of
Strickland's career yet it resulted in a
measly box office pool of less than two
hundred thousand dollars worldwide
perhaps in fabric was simply a bit too
weird to resonate with the general
public but horror aficionados are bound
to appreciate the commitment to its
throwback style Man of Tai Chi is the
first and so far only feature film
directed by everyone's favorite action
star Keanu Reeves
his love for martial arts is abundantly
apparent in this remarkably authentic
Kung Fu flick which was shot in China
and has the bulk of its dialogue spoken
in Mandarin and Cantonese Reeves's
direction is full of stylistic
Throwbacks to the Kung Fu films of days
past Reeves cast himself as the film's
main villain across from martial artist
Tiger who chin pum Reeves met during
production on The Matrix series
Reeves also brought along Matrix stunt
coordinator and legendary action
director Yin Woo ping who ensured that
Man of Tai Chi had excellent fight
scenes we want to see a pure-hearted
good-natured Man of Tai Chi become a
killer
given that Chinese was so prominent in
the film Reeves's directorial debut was
aimed more at the Asian box office than
the U.S box office and his star power in
both countries could have resulted in a
high-grossing hit instead Man of Tai Chi
unfortunately struggled to connect with
audiences in either country with the
budget of 32 million dollars which is
quite high for a Kung Fu film Man of Tai
Chi made less than 5 million dollars in
China and struggled to pull in even a
hundred thousand dollars Stateside with
his directorial debut resulting in a
massive Financial failure Reeves is
stuck to working in front of the camera
ever since
and he starred in the first John Wick
film the year after its release
spontaneous combustion is a largely
forgotten horror movie from 1989. that
languishes and obscurity today despite
being a box office failure though it
just might be worthy of a critical
reevaluation nowadays the plot of this
film follows a walking nuclear bomb
played by Brad Doran who had lint his
voice to the killer doll Chucky for the
first time the previous year when
dwarf's character gets angry Flames
erupt from his body and those around him
so naturally he embarks on a quest for
answers the plot is a tangled mess that
doesn't hold up to any amount of
scrutiny but it's still a slacky fun
time with an explosive lead performance
and incredible special effects sequences
director Toby Hooper more commonly known
for the Texas Chainsaw Massacre and
Poltergeist holds the film together even
as the script falls apart entirely
spontaneous combustion was made for a
budget of 5.5 million dollars but had
the insulting box office results of just
fifty thousand dollars before it was
pulled from theaters and seemingly
vanished from existence altogether
it was the latest in a string of box
office failures for Hooper whose career
was in a dire place by the end of the
80s the film can be quite hard to find
these days it isn't available to stream
or rent digitally and physical versions
of it are pretty rare still if a copy of
spontaneous combustion does work its way
into your life
should definitely give it a shot
released in 1980 The Ninth Configuration
was the directorial debut of William
Peter blatty the author and screenwriter
of The Exorcist just like that earlier
Smash Hit the 9th configuration was
adapted from one of bladie's novels but
unlike The Exorcist the film was a
complete failure at the box office and
has been condemned to relative obscurity
the story is set in an insane asylum run
out of a converted Gothic Castle Stacy
Keach stars as Kane a military
psychiatrist who attempts unorthodox
therapy on the various inmates who all
belong to branches of U.S government
organizations
Scott Wilson starts opposite Keech as an
astronaut who had a mental breakdown
right before he was sent into space what
sounds like the setup to another horror
film is actually a Darkly funny drama
filled with thought-provoking commentary
on the nature of religion and Humanity
who are you
I'm too human to be human Warner
Brothers was initially attached to
distribute the film but after finding
disastrous results with a limited test
release the studio canceled the planned
Nationwide theatrical rollout the scrap
distribution meant that the film's box
office earnings were virtually
non-existent and bloody's directorial
debut never had a real chance to connect
with audiences vladi only ever directed
one other film The Exorcist 3 which is
also both excellent and considered a
financial disappointment much like the
Ninth Configuration
Annihilation is a thought-provoking
Sci-Fi Adventure directed by Alex
Garland of ex machina Fame and adapted
from the novel of the same name by
author Jeff Vandermeer the story
concerns an exploratory Rescue Mission
into a Zone overtaken by an alien
substance dubbed the Shimmer which
changes the rules of biology in all
sorts of disturbing ways despite being
an all-around excellent sci-fi film
Annihilation had its chances of success
hamstrung before it was even released
the film was the unfortunate subject of
one of the most contentious and
high-profile public disputes between
producers in recent years
David Ellison of sky dance media wanted
to dumb down the movie after Poor test
screenings made him fear it was too
smart for audiences in the end Garland
was able to resist the studio pressure
and deliver on his intended Vision but
the film's distribution strategy was
essentially sabotaged as a consequence
planned theatrical distribution was
exchanged for streaming premieres in
most territories which resulted in an
otherwise avoidable failure at the box
office
writer director Robert Eggers put
himself on the map with his 2015
feature-length directorial debut the
witch a slow burn historical horror that
turned a 3.5 million dollar budget into
40 million dollars of ticket sales his
next film The Lighthouse was made for a
similarly small budget and once again
managed to turn a profit unfortunately
Edgar's third film The northmen ended
that winning streak the Northman carries
over the grungy period-piece nature of
Eggers previous films while drastically
increasing the scope of the story and
world the film is a Viking Epic with the
Flair for the supernatural that
certainly has far more mainstream appeal
than the witch or the lighthouse but it
proved to still be a bit too arthouse
for the general public though it cost
significantly more money to make the
northmen produced a smaller box office
return than Edgar's debut feature it
earned just shy of 35 million dollars at
the domestic box office a huge
disappointment for Universal Pictures
which gave the production a massive 90
million dollar budget
to make the situation even tougher it is
believed that 200 million dollars was
the true figure the film needed to hit
in order to avoid being a financial loss
after the cost of marketing and
international distribution were squared
away it's a nightmare
then you must wake up
when Edgar spoke to the Daily Beast
about the film's poor box office
performance he said
I need to re-strategize in terms of what
I'm pitching to a studio he added that
he would continue to resist taking the
tent pole Blockbuster route and stay
true to himself one way or another in
spite of concerns about marketability
Maximum Overdrive is an exceptionally
strange piece of work not least of all
because it's the only movie ever
directed by author Stephen King dozens
of films have been adapted from King's
writings but this 1986 action horror
hybrid adapted from his short story
trucks is the only one he decided to
help himself he would later admit to
being consistently high on cocaine
throughout the shoot which undoubtedly
factored into the movie turning out as
weird and messy as it did with a 10
million dollar production budget Maximum
Overdrive only earned back just shy of
7.5 million dollars at the box office
Pingas continued writing and
occasionally producing but he's never
tried his hand at directing again
despite all of its critical derision box
off his failure and Razzy Awards
nominations for King and star Emilio
Estevez Maximum Overdrive is an
exceptionally fun flick if you go in
without expecting a masterpiece the plot
revolving around machines coming to life
is fast paced and packed with creative
Death Scenes demolition derby style
vehicular Carnage and too many massive
explosions to count all scored by a
rocking AC DC soundtrack The Master is
one of the best films from acclaim.tour
Paul Thomas Anderson stunning
cinematography a challenging and
thought-provoking script and two
world-class lead performances from
Joaquin Phoenix and Philip Seymour
Hoffman culminated in a piece of work
that is routinely hailed as one of the
best films of its decade with such high
Prestige surrounding the master it's
easy to forget that it was considered a
2012 box office bomb upon release leave
it worries for a while I'll still be
there when you get back
and your memories aren't invited
concerns over the financial prospects of
the master started mounting before the
film even hit theaters it was once meant
to be handled by Universal Pictures but
the studio dropped it out of fear that
they wouldn't be able to turn a profit
on a 35 million dollar budget
Universal wound up being even more right
than they realized the film's final
budget eventually ballooned all the way
to 42 million dollars with the
additional costs mostly stemming from
Anderson's decision to shoot parts of
his film in 65 millimeter and exhibit
the finished product in 70 millimeter
the box office pole was only 16 million
dollars in the U.S after his somewhat
fumbled expansion from limited release
to wide release in the international box
office only contributed another 11
million dollars that left the film
significantly short of making back its
budget even with such overwhelming
critical Acclaim Anderson lost the
funding that was in place for his next
film after the terrible box office
results meaning he had to look elsewhere
for financing King Richard wasn't the
first sports biopic to get Will Smith
nominated for an Oscar that would be
Michael Mann's Ali an excellently acted
film starring the former Fresh Prince as
the greatest boxer who ever lived
despite the 2001 movies critical Acclaim
and Smith's Unforgettable performance as
Muhammad Ali it still didn't manage to
turn a profit Ali didn't actually
perform particularly poorly at the
domestic or international box offices it
brought in almost 90 million dollars
worldwide which would have been
considered a success if Ali hadn't been
so exorbitantly expensive the film went
into production with an already over
inflated budget of 107 million dollars
but man ended up going significantly
over budget even before making the 16
million dollar decision to extend the
shoot and relocate filming to Africa to
make matters worse Sony pumped even more
marketing dollars behind the film than
usual to try to make it a hit but they
just ended up digging themselves into a
deeper Financial hole it is believed
that Sony's total losses on the film
surpassed 100 million dollars by the
time all was said and done making Ali
one of the all-time biggest box office
disasters of this century
foreign